this is ted cruz senator for texas
high-profile republican
and now a very embarrassed man with his
state paralyzed by
arctic weather mr cruz decided to fly
with his family
to the heat of a mexican beach resort
today
he came home and admitted the trip had
been a mistake
the moment i sat on the plane i i began
really second guessing that decision and
saying look
i know why we're doing this but but i've
also got responsibilities and and it had
been my intention
to be able to to work remotely to be on
the phone to be on internet to be
on zoom to be engaged but
i needed to be here he returned to a
state that is still
struggling with power cuts intermittent
water supplies and
ice bound roads ted cruz is one of those
loving or hating figures in american
politics and there's no doubt this
trip to mexico is fuel for his critics
because while he's been away texas has
been
struggling with the after effects of the
extreme weather
in the city of plano volunteers are
handing out donations to residents who
still got no running water
much of texas is relying on this sort of
impromptu support
our systems haven't all worked out the
way we've needed them to
and so there's a lot of people that are
are hurting you know they didn't have
electricity they haven't had the heat
they've needed and then
now we've got people whose pipes are
bursting and they don't have access to
water
and so it's just been a bad collision of
a lot of things not working right and so
plano's a great community there's a lot
of people who want to step up and help
and so it's
it's nice that we have people here who
just say how can i help my fellow
neighbor
as for mr cruz's trip to cancun we
couldn't find
anyone to stick up for him he should
have never gone in the first place
yes he can't be the one out fixing
turbines and salting the roads but he's
the one that can at least get people
here to fix things
you should have stayed in the united
states you annoyed with them
yeah i mean i would this would be nice
to go on vacation too
especially when it is you know it's so
cold but
the electricity is coming back the
weather is warming the ruinous ice will
soon be gone
but restoring ted cruz's reputation may
take longer
adam parsons sky news plano texas